perhaps you could um Enlighten us with
some of the things which break IA some
of the acts which are not allowed during
IA the things
that invalidate Thea number one is
leaving the mosque without a valid
reason as I mentioned in my early answer
unless it be for relieving oneself or to
go for Call of nature for urination or
fortification or for doing wodo or
having a bath or Gul or if no one can
get food and if he has to go out to get
good these are the only conditions as a
last resort it's allowed so unless it's
for a valid reason a person cannot leave
the mask as I mentioned earlier but
nowadays alhamdulillah since there
are toilets and bathroom attached to the
mosque this requirement itself is in a
rare occasion so number one is if a
person leaves the mosque without a valid
reason Thea is invalidated number two if
a person
had sexual intercourse with his life as
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Bak
chapter number two verse number 87 that
do not associate with your wives while
you in retreat in the mosque while doing
e in the mosque don't associate with
your wife so all the schulls nously
agree that if you have a sexual
relationship with your wife Thea is
invalidated but if the wife touches you
just normally you know maybe she comes
to give you food and touches then it's
no problem at all but if your wife
touches with passion or you touch her
with
passion or you Embrace or
kiss all the scholarly agree that it is
Mak it is detestable some Scholars say
that it will break the invalid so here
the difference opinion and whether
embracing or whether touching with
passion invalid or not because this
verse of Surah Bak CH 2 verse number 187
the word mubashar
that do not associate with your wife
here if it is specific meaning that so
it means only sexual relationship so
those Scholars who say that it does not
invalidate the they take it in the
specific sense only sexual relationship
but touching with passion and kissing
and embracing it is Mak it detestable
but does not invalidate the but those
who take this word as general so they
say that besides sexual relationship
even embracing the wife or touching with
passion it invalidates the Allah Allah
knows the best the third thing that
invalidates the it is
menstruation and post Nal bleeding post
child birth bleeding the fourth thing
that invites the it is committing any
major
sin the fifth is
insanity whether the insanity is due to
Madness due to taking any drugs or
medicine or it is due to alcohol taking
any any
intoxication because the I should always
be done in sanity it should be done when
the person is sane if it's done in
sanity then the is not valid and the
last thing which
invalidates the it is
apostasy as Allah says in the Quran in
Surah aumar chapter number 39 verse
number 52
Sur aumar 39 verse number 65 that it was
revealed to you as it was revealed to
people that came before you that if you
join in worship God besides
Allah then all your fruit will be
useless it will be fruitless and in the
Hereafter you will not get reward for
all your
spirituality therefore if anyone does
shik or turns away does or apostasy then
the is invalidated so these are the six
things which
invalidate may Allah protect us from
falling into these erors and uh may
Allah ITA be accepted by Allah subhana
wa tala